lange hatte Deutschland auf den
ukrainischen Präsidenten warten müssen
wegen Steinmeiers früheren guten
Beziehungen zu putin war das Verhältnis
der beiden schwierig gestartet hallo
Herr Präsident schön sie zu sehen sagte
lensky nun
Harmonie Offensive auch im Kanzleramt
selensky hatte Scholz zu Beginn des
Krieges als zögerlich kritisiert Scholz
fand das ungerecht nun stehen sie beide
auf dem Balkon des Kanzleramtes hier war
nichts und 1990 haben wir wieder
angefangen sagt Scholz und zeigt auf
Berlin-Mitte
Wiederaufbau nach Zerstörung ist möglich
das ist wohl die Botschaft des
Bundeskanzlers
wir werden die Ukraine so lange
unterstützen wie das notwendig ist
verteidigungs- und Finanzminister haben
am Begrüßungsgeschenk für selenski
mitgearbeitet ein neues rüstungspaket
fast stolz sieht der Kanzler die
Waffensysteme auf
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte werden
weitere Kampfpanzer vom Typ Leopard 1
weitere Schützenpanzer Marder und
aristine
erhalten der ukrainische Präsident will
noch mehr Waffen der Kanzler schmunzelt
deshalb und dann gibt es selensky ein
wichtiges Versprechen ab
wir greifen keine russischen Gebiete an
wir haben dazu auch gar nicht die Kraft
und wir haben dafür auch gar keine
Waffen übrig mit denen wir das tun
könnten wir bereiten eine Gegenoffensive
vor um unsere besetzten Gebiete zu
befreien
ich würde dir
2 Station von selensky Aachen die Stadt
ganzem Zeichen der Sicherheit er und das
ukrainische Volk bekommen den Karlspreis
für die Verteidigung der europäischen
Werte Dank an das deutsche Volk und den
Bundeskanzler
als du Olaf die zeitenwände ausgerufen
hast hast du angefangen so zu handeln
wie der Verteidiger Europas handeln
sollte Europa wird dir immer dankbar
sein
Europa und Deutschland feiern silenski
in der Hoffnung auf Frieden
wir wollen über das und mehr sprechen
mit Christian Mölling er ist
verteidigungsexpert und Leiter des
Zentrums für Sicherheit und Verteidigung
in Berlin guten Morgen Herr möhling
hallo guten Morgen wir bilanzieren den
selensky Besuch hier in Deutschland
markiert dieser Besuch für sie eine
Wende vielleicht was die Strategie oder
das Verhältnis angeht
zumindest erstmal das Verhältnis die von
beiden Seiten klargemachte message ist
es gibt eine Vergangenheit die war
vielleicht nicht so schön und es gibt
vielleicht eine gute Zukunft das ist
aber jetzt erstmal sozusagen ein
schlaglich dieses Moment ist das aber
glaube ich gelungen ist dann gab es eine
großzügige ein großzügiges Geschenk das
war natürlich lange vorbereitet wie das
geschnürt wurde Waffen zu sagen Wert von
2,7 Milliarden Euro Kampf Schützenpanzer
Drohnen Luftabwehrsysteme wie sehr wird
dass der Ukraine helfen ja wenn es jetzt
schnell kommt hilft es natürlich
besonders gut das ist völlig klar ich
glaube dass man sich einfach darauf
einstellen muss das ist nicht das letzte
Paket das geschnürt werden musste
sondern wir im Grunde genommen in der
Phase wo die Ukraine irgendwann mal von
einem akuten Kriegszustand in einen
verteidigungs- oder abschreibungszustand
gehen muss das heißt sie muss weiterhin
kontinuierlich über die nächsten Jahre
wahrscheinlich sogar Jahrzehnte
unterstützt werden das ist die die
Herausforderung vor der Deutschland aber
gesamt Europa eigentlich stehen
interessanter Besuch eigentlich von
selensky eigentlich muss man sagen
Europa Tournee erst Italien dann
Deutschland jetzt ist er weiter nach
Frankreich und gestern viel ja mehrmals
auch das Wort Kampfjet und er hat
Deutschland gebeten doch damit zu helfen
mit einzuwirken eine mögliche Kampfjet
Allianz aufzubauen wie realistisch ist
der sowas bedeutet das überhaupt also
hängt glaube ich ganz davon ab was er
genau sich darunter vorstellt oder wie
offen er dazu ist dass Deutschland
möglicherweise und da ein paar Beiträge
auf finanzieller hat leistet aber sich
jetzt nicht mit Flugzeugen daran
beteiligen wird wenn sie so eine super
gemischte Flotte haben und Flugzeugen
dann ist das eigentlich eher logistisch
gesehen die Hölle die sich da aufmachen
sind unheimlich teuer in der Versorgung
wenn man es schaffen könnte die Ukraine
eben mit Blick auf diese langfristige
Perspektive mit ein oder zwei
Flugzeugtypen auszurüsten und
Deutschland das Finanzielle unterstützt
dann ist der Ukraine glaube ich mehr
geholfen und Deutschland auch nun liest
man ja jetzt das Rheinmetall in der
Ukraine vor Ort auch mit Panzern mit
Panzerproduktion aktiv werden will das
ist ja dann doch etwas was ja auch lange
vorbereitet werden muss das heißt es
muss ja Gespräche gegeben haben zwischen
Industrie und und Kanzleramt was
bedeutet das langfristig oder
mittelfristig dass das man sich quasi
auf eine wirklich lange Zeit einstellt
wenn so ein Schritt erfolgt ja ich
glaube es passiert das was wir schon
lange angeraten haben nämlich im Grunde
genommen die Ukraine schrittweise in das
Verteidigungssystem Europas zu
integrieren auch auf der industriellen
Seite und darf nicht vergessen die
Ukraine hat lange Zeit lang selber
moderne Waffen hergestellt nicht in
allen Bereichen aber auch gerade im Land
Bereich von daher gibt das worauf man
aufbauen kann
immer wieder in den letzten Wochen wird
in die Glaskugel geguckt sie werden da
natürlich häufig bemüht als
verteidigungsexpert und
sicherheitsexpert es geht um die
Frühjahrsoffensive die die Ukraine
angekündigt hat die einen sagen ja die
findet schon längst statt die anderen
sagen ja dann kommt das aber mit Pauken
und Trompeten
wie weit ist man
genau das ist der Blick in die Glaskugel
ich glaube das muss man sich auf alle
Fälle nicht vorstellen kann was man da
sieht ist sozusagen ein Sonnenaufgang
und dann werden die Motoren angeworfen
dann beginnt diese Offensive es ist ganz
viel Aufklärungsarbeit dabei ob das
jetzt schon tatsächlich läuft das ist
ein sehr schleichender Übergang die man
da sehen wird sie ist auf alle Fälle
noch nicht voll im Gange aber man kann
trotzdem danach fragen also um Gebiete
zurück zu erobern da müssten die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte
russische Verteidigungslinie
durchbrechen das ist eine hochkomplexe
sehr sehr anspruchsvolle militärische
Operation ist die ukrainische Armee dazu
überhaupt in der Lage und ich glaube ein
wichtiger Baustein ist in der letzten
Woche bekannt geworden nehme ich das
jetzt endlich lang reichweiteige
Marschflugkörper geliefert worden sind
die geben der Ukraine zumindest die
Chance die Logistik der Russlands unter
Beschuss zu nehmen und damit im Grunde
genommen ist möglich zu machen dass die
russischen Truppen an der Front quasi
ausgetrocknet werden sie keine Munition
sie keinen Treibstoff mehr haben so dass
sie sich dann möglicherweise früher
ergeben müssen und man einen Teil der
Linien gar nicht durchbrechen muss
zumindest nicht gegen die Kampfkraft der
russischen Verbände ah das ist
interessant man liest da an diesem
Zusammenhang von 12 bis 18.9 regimenten
die sind dann jeweils mit mehreren
tausend Soldaten bestückt sondern es ist
auf jeden Fall sehr interessant es gibt
immer neuerliche Zusagen was Waffen
angeht nicht nur von Deutschland massig
heute wahrscheinlich wird das auch in
Frankreich erfolgen denke ich mal aber
das Thema Munition das war aber immer
über einen Moment ist sich nie sicher
was nützen all die Waffen wenn es keine
Munition gibt bzw keine vernünftige
Produktion dessen ja gar nichts
zumindest nicht wenn es um den die
Bereich Artillerie und Infanterie gibt
es gibt braucht die Munition und ich
glaube da sind wir noch am Anfang von
kreativen Lösungen wo man einfach gucken
muss dass man nicht nur in Europa die
Dinge herstellt und von europäischen
Herstellern das muss uns glaube ich aus
meiner Sicht ziemlich egal sein es ist
egal woher die Munition kommt Hauptsache
ist die Ukraine hat genug denn dann kann
der Krieg halt verkürzt werden lassen
sie uns ganz am Schluss noch ganz kurz
über das Thema Friedensverhandlungen
sprechen da gibt es im Grunde zwei Lager
die einen sagen das kann man auf gar
keinen Fall machen weil Putin darauf
besteht ja ich wir können über Frieden
reden wenn alles so bleibt wie jetzt
gerade ist also aktueller Status Quo und
die anderen sagen äh nein das ist ja
völlig in diskutabel und ich würde gerne
wissen auf welcher Seite sie stehen ich
glaube sie können niemanden zu einem
Frieden zwingen wieder Putin noch die
Ukraine wichtig ist dass das was dann
nachher als endstatus rauskommt
tatsächlich nicht nur morgen sondern
auch übermorgen noch Geld und da muss
jeder selber fragen ob er dem Gegenüber
vertraut und ob das gerade Richtung tut
sagt Christian Mölling Sicherheit und
verteidigungsexperte heute morgen im
Interview das Thema
Friedensverhandlungen später auch bei
uns noch mal ausführlicher beleuchtet im
Moment Duell dankeschön